number two says when are you going to
interview daniel
diana pasulka i've already done so and
again thumbnail here
and i'll just read from the description
that i that i wrote for diana pasulka
the recent interview with diana is one
that i'm particularly proud of why
broadly speaking there are two subsets
of the toe audience those interested
heavily in the philosophical material
physics b
those interested in the ufo oriented
content
while these groups
overlap substantially what's distinct
about the diana episode is that it
merges both perspicuously and
beautifully in fact i blatantly didn't
put a ufo tag in the title or the
thumbnail if you're interested in
religion and philosophy then this deep
dive is one of the best on toe for
audience a that is the
philosophical physics related
subset while showing how it intersects
with the quote-unquote phenomenon which
is aligned with audience b this will
introduce new topics and models of
thinking to each group though again a
and b are not mutually exclusive
the conversation with diana was filled
with such mutual respect and love akin
to the carlo revelli episode especially
when we were gushing over heidegger i
see the toe project as an extension of
heidegger's main themes and i consider
him to be a row what is a row
it's an internal name i have i actually
haven't said this
aloud yet it's an internal name that's
false i mean
i've said it aloud it hasn't been
published it's an internal name that i
have for resiners of existence which
i'll expand upon more in an upcoming ama
which is this i'll do so shortly it's a
name that i have for the types of people
who are trying to understand reality who
don't scorn other approaches like
secular or religion or religious
traditions they include yoshibak
castro
levin donald hoffman and so on and so on
okay so rezner what is a resiner it's a
french term and it's a term of art
which means the person who voices the
central theme philosophy or point of
view of a work of
of
well of a piece of work
generally you see this in movies when
someone toward the end of the film
encapsulates what the
motif was of the film or the point of
the film was
and does so beautifully they often do so
as if they're speaking to another
character but you can tell it's it's
exposition for us as the audience
members passively viewing it
if it's written well it wouldn't seem
like that
so
why do i call them resonators of
existence well one can think of this
like a play in some sense the story of
life
and
i feel like there
aren't many people who are
deeply wrestling or contending with what
existence is because most academics feel
like well
it's ill-defined it's nebulous you
shouldn't even think about it if it's if
it's unclear what it means
but yet there are people like yoshibak
and
bernardo castro and donald hoffman and
roger penrose and carl fristen and john
verveiki and greg henriques who are
i'd say they're investigating
fundamental reality from an extremely
originative perspective they don't have
a disdain for non-secular spirituality
which is also rare they have developed
their point of view
pretty much singularly and they also
have a flare for rigor so that's the
four conditions that i have for a row
another way that i think about it is in
mathematics there's something called
associativity so there's commutativity
i'm sure you've heard of x times y is
not the same as y times x always when
they are they're commutative then
there's associativity which which has to
do with placing brackets around
the objects and saying that you can
place brackets anywhere so
as an aside chris fields believes that
because quantum mechanics has
associativity in it it implies that
observers itself and so on are illusory
or could be made to be
could be made to have flexible
boundaries but that's
that's not always true there are
formulations of quantum mechanics and
they're unifications of quantum
mechanics and general relativity which
are based in the octonians which are
non-associative so you can't place the
brackets anywhere a times b bracketed
times c is not the same as
a bracket b times c bracket close
bracket i'm speaking to someone shortly
named to jinder singh who has an
octahonic metal meter sorry
has an octanic
model of the
of unification
regardless the point of this was to make
the analogy that i view the
rose the resinors of existence as a
non-associative philosophical rat pack
and
it's complicated to ex to explain more
about what that means so hopefully
this little
teaser has
has done so
oftentimes people ask me
hey you should interview this person or
this person and and sure the choices in
my head come down to yes they have a toe
but are they a row
perhaps no
boris costello says haha man i'd love to
know how you get such
a rich vocabulary coming from math and
physics
i i don't boris thank you i'm constantly
struggling i appreciate the compliment
it's undeserved
i
i don't
personally i don't understand how people
can live stream this is extremely
intimidating it's it requires an extreme
amount of courage to extemporize
unfettered in an unfettered manner
they're either people who live stream
are either greatly skilled or they have
huge amounts of hearty hood
courage valor and so on or they are
or i'm greatly unskilled or
or
they're saying someone else's thoughts
and it's and the reason i say that is
because it's extremely extremely
difficult to think for oneself it's
extremely difficult
it takes me
me
for instance many minutes to articulate
sometimes a single thought that i feel
like is my own
by the way boris is
someone that
who
has been a fan of the theories of
everything channel for a while and then
messaged me on
messaged me and said hey kurt i would
love to invite you out to
to montreal and take
photos
of you because i'm a cg artist and i do
compositing and here's some of my work
and i looked at it and it was
absolutely gorgeous
and here's his instagram for people who
would like to use boris for their
upcoming shoots
he has worked on marvel films and star
wars films and continues to do so his
instagram is at gaelic pic so that is at
g-a-l-a-c-p-i-c
and his linkedin will be put in the
description as well i recommend you
subscribe or follow i'm unsure of how
instagram works what the terminology is
his work because it's
it's
it's unparalleled
graphic design and photography it's a
combination of both thank you again
boris it was great to meet you and
soon those photos will come onto the tow
channel and i'll place them somewhere
maybe i'll do a special video about them
crescendo both says when are you
interviewing chiara marletto so whenever
she responds to my emails and again
similarly to anna kramer for stephen
greer feel free to email chara
chiara marletto and let her know that
hey perhaps you should come on the toe
channel it would be great i would love
to see you there every email to someone
else does help because often mine either
goes to spam or they're flooded with
many requests that they have to see it
repeated in order for them to feel like
it's worth it